ce fip et rodin qui décide donc de tout
faire pour repartir dans son pays de
coeur mettant la france dans l'embarras
comment ce retour a donc pu être
possible sans visa en pleine pandémie de
surcroît pourquoi la prends ton
seulement maintenant beaucoup de zones
d'ombré qu'on va tenter d'analyser c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
en parler sur ce plateau régis le
sommier grand reporter rt france bonsoir
régis vos côtés un petit peu plus loin
on duplex jean paul garraud député
européen rassemblement national bonsoir
monsieur garraud drissi canon mbaye
président du collectif malien de
belgique bonsoir monsieur claude mailly
merci d'être avec nous donc sept mois
déjà quand même que sophie petrona on le
rappelle son âge 75 ans est de retour au
magic qui ont des styles mans réussir à
faire ce périple que nous a décrit david
kelly fin alors que les demandes de
visas en précises ont été refusées deux
fois par le mali en pleine pandémie on
se souvient qu on était tous plus ou
moins assigné à résidence impossible de
voyager ça paraît complètement fou et
g10 ça paraît complètement fou puis
surtout ce temps le les sept mois que
vous indiquez que dans lesquelles elle
aurait été présente au mali cc c'est
absolument incroyable
d'autant qu' on peut imaginer vu ses
déclarations quand elle avait été
libérée la première fois quand elle est
revenue en europe elle avait signalé
déjà qu'elle souhaitait retourner vivre
au mali ce fip et rodin c'est quelqu'un
qui fait partie
du sérail locale qui est qui et une
africaine de coeur et qui a là bas donc
une fille adoptive qui a d'abord eu un
orphelinat puis donc elle a fait
beaucoup de choses et l'afrique pour
elle c'est son pays donc elle s'est dit
elle a dit qu'elle ne se plaisait pas en
suisse là on l'avait mise en résidence
et il ya cette incroyable perrig en
effet dans lequel on peut se dire mais
comment est-ce que quelqu'un qui a été
otage justement peut arriver à nouveau à
traverser les frontières
retournez dans le son pays de détention
puisque visiblement apparemment elle ne
serait pas à sissoko mai à bamako
avec l'intention de revenir vivre là où
elle était quasiment l jean paul garraud
on va après voilà lé plus loin dans dans
ses conséquences mais enfin sur ce
diagnostic partir comme ça sans visa
sans rien en pleine pandémie est ce que
selon vous il ya une faille tout
simplement
dans les frontières ou ton bonne lors on
ne peut pas empêcher un citoyen avec un
passeport de d'aller où il veut
ça fait longtemps qu'on sait
malheureusement que les frontières il y
en a plus et que tout ceci ressemble à
une sorte de comédie qui aurait pu être
dramatique d'ailleurs moi je j'ai de
nombreuses réactions par rapport à cela
comme de très nombreux français je peux
dire que je suis assez ou très si ce
n'est scandalisé par ce qui vient de se
passer déjà je l'avais été au moment de
la libération de sept personnes qui
avaient eu un comportement très
particulier lorsqu'elle était arrivé au
mois d'octobre 2001 sa tenue déjà le
voile islamique enfin ces déclarations
qui étaient à la limite du remerciement
enfin c'était très très très particulier
et puis tout ce qui a entouré cette
libération dont on ne sait d'ailleurs
pas trop ce qui s'est passé on parle
effectivement déjà de 200 djihadistes
qui avaient été libérés et là j'ai quand
même une pause c'est direct pour tous
nos militaires et en particulier pour
les cinq hommes sept militaires français
qui sont morts d'un coup ma vie en
opération en cinquante six hommes et une
femme parce que j'ai courent des risques
terribles et puis donc tout ceci si vous
voulez la connotation qui ne rend son
qui auraient été versés on ne sait pas
trop alors quand j'entends
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement français
indique qu'il n'a pas pris part à tout
cela mais alors que faisait le président
de la république le ministre des
affaires étrangères le chef d'état major
des armées et d'autres ministres lorsque
effectivement l'avion transportant sept
personnes est arrivée en france non il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont bien sûr la france a participé à
cette libération est ce que c'était
vraiment une libération puisque cette
personne manifestement était-elle
vraiment otages jusqu au bout de quatre
ans soit dix ans de captivité la
première des choses qu'elle fait ou peu
qu'elle tente de faire et elle a réussi
là récemment c'est revenir effectivement
dans le pays dans lequel elle a été
enlevée en rien au comportement pour
quelqu'un qui a été en captivité mais
j'ai d'autres d'autres évidemment
réaction par rapport on va bien
évidemment sur les conditions de cette
libération des cinq anneaux de beille
vous avez pouvoir peut-être nous
éclairer parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup de zones d'ombré on sait
effectivement s'en est pas cachée sophie
petrona au lieu de considérer ses
ravisseurs comme des terroristes elle
les a qualifiés de groupe d'opposition
armée au régime clairement elle avait
entre guillemets sympathisé becker s'est
convertie d'ailleurs à l'islam et on
sait aussi que la libération c'est 200
islamistes ma foi a constitué à l'époque
un vrai succès pour pour les djihadistes
il faut le rappeler
et bien tout à fait en fait la situation
est générale et ressemble un peu à une
tragi-comédie bien organisée mais moi
honnêtement
c'est dommage que de diane east qui ont
commis des crimes aient été libérés
rencontre
sa libération est aussi d'autres
d'autres prisonniers etc mais
[Applaudissements]
c'était un homme politique à l'époque
qui était qu'on voulait libérer en
premier et pas nécessairement son fip et
ronan et il faut le rappeler
oui mais bon ça c'est qu'on le dit mais
c'est pas le regretter soumaila cissé
n'était pas je pense que si il était
seul
l'application de tous ses états
n'auraient pas été
comme ça c'était passé donc il faut pas
quand même il n'y aurait que c'était une
française étaient les autorités
françaises ont effectivement été
impliqué quand même dans la libération
de ces otages là donc ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on ne peut pas même si
officiellement on a tendance à démentir
mais en réalité ils ont quand même bien
participé à la libération
de sous mais là avec soshy peut-être
mais régis le sommier oui est-ce que ce
qu'on a ce qu'il faut rajouter d'abord
c'est que on se souvient quand même que
c'est le fils même de sophie pétrole 1
qui avait à l'époque attirer l'attention
sur l'état de santé de sa mère savait
était son combat jusqu'à sa libération
là visiblement on apprend qu'il a été
aussi qu'il était au courant voire qu'il
aurait été comme
son retour donc on peut se demander
vraiment pourquoi avoir demandé cette
libération si cette femme finalement été
à l'aise et vivait au milieu de ces
groupes ça c'est le premier point qui
est obscur qu'il faudra éclaircir
l'autre aspect c'est que dans ces
négociations là et aujourd'hui à
d'autres niveaux parce que là il
s'agissait de groupe qui détenait donc
sous les 1000 soul et soumaila cissé et
ce fip et romain ces deux personnes à
l'époque donc il y avait une négociation
qui était en cours aujourd'hui
négociations que les maliens à mener
aujourd'hui les manières son passé un
autre niveau d'hier il négocie
directement avec ryad al ghali qui est
donc le le comment l'un des chefs
djihadistes et et amadou pouffa qui est
donc le chef de la katiba macina donc
ils ont entrepris des négociations
directes avec des personnes que les
troupes françaises sur place ont dans le
viseur et cherche à éliminer donc on est
dans un dans une partie il ya évidemment
dans la leur dans l' annonce da par dès
maliens de la présence de sophie pétrole
1 une manière encore une fois
d'embarrasser les français on est dans
une situation où la france les relations
entre la france et le mali sont
extrêmement tendues mais les maliens
aujourd'hui sont à la 7 e qui qui mène
ces négociations et et dans ce cadre là
bon pourquoi avoir attendu sept mois
peut-être que il y avait aussi des
menaces que est également que que ce fip
être en 1 re devienne otages c'était une
possibilité mais en tout cas on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que la france est
et quand même même si elle participe de
de certaines négociations
elle est quand même tenu à l'écart de
beaucoup de choses et qu'aujourd'hui
on négocie au maître directement avec
des gens que nos soldats sont censés tu
es donc il ya un interrogations
légitimes je pense aujourd'hui sur le
sens de la mission de la france la
mission barkan emmanuel macron être
signé à signaler la fin de cette
opération ça fait huit ans que la france
est présente au mali aujourd'hui il faut
quand même revoir les choses de fond
parce que le mali que le main event
intégrer des groupes comme les jeux
nîmes ou avoir des dialogues avec eux ou
en tout cas tenter de les faire revenir
dans l'échiquier national c'est une
possibilité peut-être que ça sera contre
le vivier est ce qui est des shows qui
est donc l'émanation des chais qui se
trouve plus au sud avec lequel il ya peu
de négociation possible mais en tout cas
ce que le gouvernement malien tente de
faire notamment via l'imam dicko qui est
toujours un petit peu à la manoeuvre
dans ses dents dans ce type de
négociation bien on remarque que on est
au plus haut niveau aujourd'hui en
discussion le gouvernement malien avec
des chefs de groupes terroristes 'sur
une possible en restant la france a les
cas on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
continuer avec une opération markalou
même des opérations de forces spéciales
qui vise à éliminer les chefs
djihadistes quand le gouvernement malien
lui même négocié avec eux jean paul
garraud dans le prolongement de ce que
vient de dire régis le sommier c'est
vrai que un journaliste proche de sophie
près trône un anthony aux faucheurs qui
s'est un peu exprimée dans tous les
médias aujourd'hui affirme en tout cas
que la suisse savait qu'elle repartirait
d'ailleurs elle avait dit dès le début
un la france savait manifestement
qu'elle était revenue à bamako
d'ailleurs elle ne se cachait pas dans
les rues de la ville l'information a
commencé à circuler il ya quatre jours
après la publication sur les réseaux
sociaux par justement la gendarmerie
malienne ça veut dire quoi vous êtes
d'accord avec ce diagnostic de registre
sommier la france est manifestement un
petit peu tenu à l'écart des choses
écoutez moi je suis là aussi effaré de
voir la situation de la france parce que
derrière le cas petronas est en fait la
france elle même est complètement
discrédité et qui a nouvelle fois une
nouvelle fois est tenue pour en quelque
sorte la risée du monde comment peut-on
imaginer des situations comme celle là
une situation où là france est tenue à
l'écart
de ce qui se passe actuellement c'est à
dire de négociation qu'il y aurait entre
effectivement des terroristes et les
autorités maliennes alors que nous
sommes censés protéger le mali au moins
peut-on imaginer ce marché de dupes dont
la france a été pas victimes mais ce qui
montre parce que le terme serait
finalement un peu trop gentil pour les
autorités françaises ont c'est un marché
de dupes parce que nos autorités n'ont
pas été à la hauteur de la situation
elle se sont fait berner voilà et
aujourd'hui quand le gouvernement
cherche à à dire qu'il n'est pas partie
prenante dans cette affaire en réalité
il sait très bien que tout ceci va
revenir sur lui
c'est une catastrophe en réalité
imaginez quand même la situation de tout
bon militaire français au mali depuis
huit ans de leurs familles de cette
situation
où on a eter le 10e 10 pas
officiellement mais ils le disent
évidemment on le sait c'est terrible
quel est le sens de l'engagement de la
france au mali dans ces conditions là
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une
situation qui si vous voulez qui dépasse
l'entendement
la france ne représente plus rien dans
cette histoire et c'est dramatique moi
ça me fait mal comme de nombreux
français il faut il est temps qu'on
revienne aux sujets principaux de la
france reprenne sa place dans le concert
des nations et dise les choses pourquoi
de sa position et on arrête de faire la
communication et des opérations de
publicité pour le gouvernement qui
tourne effectivement très mal est là
avec cette affaire est true name is et
bien c'est à nouveau et c'est le signe
que ce qui s'est passé en réalité brice
à kananga et vous partagez ces
diagnostics à travers cette affaire pour
le moins rocambolesque ça interroge
clairement sur ses relations entre la
france et le mali
non moi je crois qu'il n'y a pas une
volonté
manifeste et vraiment c'est pas par
gaieté de coeur que le mali cherche à
négocier ou à interroger les différentes
parties c'est pas pour moi ce n'est pas
une manière de bien nova qui est qui
nous sommes liés
pour longtemps en tout cas j'espère mais
c'est en désespoir de cause que ces gens
essayent de trouver d'autres pistes et
parce que
le mali aujourd'hui est sûre militarisé
il ya il ya les nations-unies à la
france et à la cedeao il ya tout le
monde qui est là qui sont là bas mais en
réalité quand vous les ventes et les
résultats c'est vraiment des milliers de
villages qui sont ou ont été effacées de
la tarte de du pays il ya aujourd'hui
plus de 1600 écoles fermées bon quand on
voit un terme des résultats c'est à dire
que nous pouvons quand même saluer la
mémoire effectivement de ces femmes et
ces hommes qui ont perdu la vie en
essayant de protéger d'autres personnes
mais quand on regarde les ré les
résultats de tout c est de toutes ses
interventions et on était un peu la
chronologie de l'histoire je vous assure
que c'est par désespoir de cause que les
gens essayent de chercher d'autres
solutions mais je ne crois pas que
disait de gouvernement à une certaine
volonté d'écarter qui que ce soit mais
ils sont aussi aujourd'hui dans
l'ouverture de pouvoir vraiment
trouver une solution par tous les moyens
parce que c'est impossible quand vous
prenez par exemple de santé du mali moi
je viens du pays de gros alors on ne
peut même pas se déplacer de ces vallées
à m'intégrer donc on a tout perdu moi
qui vous parle aujourd'hui j'étais pro
sécurité ti il ya des villages qui ont
été carrément incendie est maintenant là
l'insécurité montre jusqu'aux jusqu'à
ses roues c'est à dire que la région de
ségou à 200 km de bamako où on est en
train de brûler et toutes les récoltes
même les machines agricoles nous on a on
n'a pas le choix on ne sait pas comment
faire on ne sait pas à quel saint se
vouer donc je ne crois pas que et de
manière intentionnelle il ya une volonté
de décanter la phrase même je crois qu
aujourd'hui là où nous sommes
toutes les solutions sont les bienvenus
pour vraiment
arrêter cette hémorragie qui n'a que
trop duré donc en ce qui concerne
s'occuper tron est aussi bon moi je m'en
tiens un peu à la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
l'article 13 qui dit que toute personne
a le droit à la mobilité etc mais moi
aussi je crois que la solution aurait
été de pouvoir l'encadrer et non
l'enfermer parce que l'on a horreur du
tabou donc on a le temps là attendez
l'interdît donc mais la dame au mali
depuis masse donc je ne vois pas
pourquoi est-ce que c'est maintenant
d'ailleurs que cette question est
soulevée c'est bien la question
justement con con qu'on se pose et qui
interroge en régie sur ce que disait
dresser un cadre global moi je trouve
qu'il ya du vent est évidemment dans ce
qui vient d'être dit c'est sûr que si le
mali aujourd'hui a décidé de prendre son
destin en main c'était un peu quand même
le but au départ de l'opération serval
et de l'opération barkan qui a suivi
c'était faire en sorte qu'une fois la
situation militaire et sécuritaire
rétabli ce qu'elle a été dans un premier
temps et bien le mali reprennent les
mails et les comores les lits les rênes
de son destin et s'affirmer et on commet
malheureusement ce qu'on remarque c'est
que dans dont m sous l'autorité du
président précédent premier ministre ib
cas et bien le mali est parti à vau de
l'eau le mali est devenu un état failli
aujourd'hui je pense que dans la boue
une grande explication une grande des
grandes explications du coup d'état
militaire
comment diriger par à 6000 ou état a été
justement de mettre un terme justement à
cette cette dérive de commandes du pays
et au fait que le pays connaisse
justement une véritable de commande un
véritable démantèlement le mali est un
état failli le mettre le mali est un
état où les comment l'autorité ne
s'exerce plus dans certaines provinces
où il ya des zones entières qui sont
tombées aux mains de bandes armées parce
qu'il ya pas que les djihadistes on
parle des djihadistes mais il ya aussi
énormément
comment d'opportunistes de gens qui qui
voilà qui pilent des régions entières et
et donc les déplacements de population
les comment les affrontements ethniques
ça a été ça a été l'explosion donc
aujourd'hui le mali essaye de négocier
avec un certain nombre de groupes moi je
pense que c'est une c'est un véritable
progrès je pense qu'il ya ils font kill
kill que ça continue il faut que le mali
rétablisse les services publics dans
certains endroits vous avez moi j'ai
beaucoup de passes et de temps avec
comment avec les soldats français au
mali dans le cadre de l'opération barkan
vous avez des villes comme une d'elimane
par exemple à côté de ménaka ça fait
deux ans quasiment qui a pas de présence
militaire parce que les djihadistes ont
attaqué une fois et que la garnison est
parti donc si vous voulez il faut que
l'état le malien se réaffirme c'est ce
que je pense que ce que les autorités
maliennes ont la volonté maintenant sur
le cap et ronan on peut pas dire cette
personne a le droit à la mobilité quand
on sait que ce droit à la mobilité a
provoqué la libération de 200 jihadistes
et je rappelle que ces 210 à dist pour
les arrêter pour les mettre en prison un
certain nombre de noces de nos forces et
de nos soldats sont morts pour ça donc
voilà donc cesser c'est pas possible de
faire ça cette personne si elle désirait
rester au début elle aurait très bien pu
rester avec ces groupes personne ne
l'aurait empêché son fils a alerté
l'opinion souvenez vous des articles de
presse ma mère est en train de mourir
etc etc et on s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui
ces gens sont irresponsables il le fils
non seulement la compagne pour qu'elle
revienne si elle ne disait désirait pas
partir et bien qu'elle qu'elle y reste
au mali voilà c'est tout jean paul
garraud le mot de la fin
oui mais écoutez moi je rejoins ce qui
vient d'être dit je dirai simplement en
conclusion que madame trip rétro n'a
effectivement risque d'être à nouveau
aux tâches
captive et bien surtout qu'on ne
prennent aucun risque pour la libérer
mais vraiment aucun risque et que nos
soldats ne prennent aucun risque si
jamais elle venait à nouveau à être
captivant parce que je me pose même la
question de savoir si elle était
vraiment otages et je me demande aussi
en ce qui concerne le double jeu
semble-t-il qui a été menée par son fils
de ce site une sombre affaire et je
prends que la france n'a rien à faire
avec le cap et rosé merci beaucoup en
tout cas tous les trois jean paul
garraud régis le sommier drissa
kalambayi remercie d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france